on va poursuivre en analyse avec serge
coulombe et les professeur émérite à
l'université d'ottawa bonsoir monsieur
coulombe
bonjour un homme s'était donc déficit
on le disait projeté de 343 milliards de
dollars ça donne le vertige
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour les
finances canadienne mais je pensais
jamais avoir un déficit comme ça de ma
vie ici c'est un pas très de crise qui
est la plus forte depuis les années 30
est aussi tous les pays du monde qui
font face à cette crise est présentement
on se retrouve avec une baisse de
l'activité économique et des mesures de
soutien du gouvernement qui font en
sorte que le canada a omis de lavande
dès lors qu'il pays avec la mainguais
japon qui ont mis de la bande le plus de
mesures pour pour soutenir l'économie
donc on est parmi les trois pays au
monde qui vont justement à dépenser le
plus en matière de soutien de revenus
avec l'allemagne et le japon
donc oui on a fait plus que les autres
mais on en fait à peu près dans dans le
même niveau que l'allemagne et le japon
donc cédé des mesures de 14% du pib
écouter avant la crise on parlait de
difficile de un an et demi pour cent du
pib
on se retrouve avec 14 donc c'est non
c'est une situation qui est entièrement
inusités et il est beaucoup trop tôt
pour savoir
c'est face à l'incertitude
bon là aujourd'hui on a eu une
estimation la première estimation des
coûts des mesures qui ont été déployés
être qu'on va récolter des fruits tous
savent qu'on a évité le pire en
investissement ou en dépensant autant
monsieur chrome
les proches retenu par le gouvernement
libéral effet très très clair dans les
documents présentés aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il favorise à tout prix la santé des
canadiens
il a donc essentiellement
des mesures pour soutenir l'économie
pour faire en sorte que les canadiens
qui ne travaillent pas est des revenus
de façon à ce qu'ils puissent subvenir à
leurs besoins
une autre approche aurait été de vouloir
également relancer l'économie comme
d'autres pays l'ont fait c'était fait un
magnifique problème de finances
publiques est ce qu'on doit relancer
l'économie au risque de relancer
également la contagion ou est-ce qu'on
doit mettre l'accent sur la santé
publique
le gouvernement libéral a remis 100 % de
ses oeufs dans le panier de la santé
publique s'est il est trop tôt pour
faire un post mortem
il est clair que on ne sera dans un an
et demi ou deux mais vous savez quand on
fait face à des situations complètement
incertaine les gouvernements sont amenés
à prendre des décisions et ces décisions
lors facilement être critiquée par des
observateurs mais attendent endroit où
est ce que tout ça va aller parce que
regarder on se retrouve avec l'allemagne
et le japon qui est qui qui en font
autant que nous et c'est les deux pays
les deux groupes et industrialisés qui
ont eu le moins de morts avec l'accord
du 19 au canada on a eu plus uniquement
parce que la situation a dégénéré dans
les foyers pour personnes âgées au
québec et en ontario mais sinon on se
retrouverait également avec un excellent
bilan en matière d'amour donc et c'est
l'échec
les pays qui ont le plus faible taux de
mortalité sont ceux qui ont le plus
dépensé pour soutenir les ménages et
pour s'assurer que personne ne soit
forcée d'aller travailler même si cela
amène des risques pour sa santé dans
présentement ça fonctionne la proche
frontière
qu'est ce qui va arriver dans six mois
dans un an
mais ça on le sait pas mais c'est un peu
ça le problème c'est que ça a déjà coûté
très cher on le voit aujourd'hui
là on a l'impression que le gouvernement
puisse un coffre n'y a pas de fond est
ce qui limitait ce qu'on peut dépenser
parce qu'il va peut-être justement y
avoir d'autres vins mousseux coulon oui
justement les coûts de financement comme
monsieur morneau lentilles sont les plus
chères d'historiquement au canada il
faut comprendre que depuis le mois de
mars qui 200 milliards de dette du
gouvernement fédéral qui aurait été
achetée par la banque qui n'a d'autre
c'est du jamais vu
sur le plan historique donc c'est
évident que pour le grand fédéral ça
coûte tellement cher pour en profiter
qu'est ce que c'est le banquier qui
arrive avec 200 millions deux cents ans
est ce que c'est un pubis enfants en
temps normal lorsque la banque centale
monétise la tête public comme il le fait
présentement le risque c'est que
l'inflation sur vienne et on est une
augmentation des taux d'emprunt du
gouvernement comme dans les années 80 et
90 comme monsieur morneau lozzi ça ne
s'est pas produit en 2008 2009 pour les
américains qui ont eu recours à cette
approche
tout simplement parce que c'était
uniquement un choc de demande qu'on
avait à l'époque mais aujourd'hui on est
également une baisse de l'or parce que
les gens ne peuvent pas travailler en
match c'est que si on continue à
soutenir les revenus et que les gens le
travail port on va avoir une
augmentation de consommation pas
d'importation de production et ça peut
être le début d'un passionné c'est ma
crainte donc le puits n'est pas sans
s'en voit clairement bon là à partir de
maintenant si l'on sent vraiment les
finances publiques le gouvernement dit
on veut pas élever les impôts on veut
postuler dans les services est ce que ça
se peut c'est clair que c'est pas le tas
de coups de d'augmenter les impôts ou de
couper dans les services présentement
c'est ce manoir a sûrement raison
la question va se poser dans deux ou
trois ans qu'est ce qui va arriver
et puis peut-être un peu avant et tout
dépend de ce qui va arriver avec le
financement avec des acquisitions
d'actifs également par la banque du
canada des pays comme la france
et le royaume uni non pas du tout
l'action de financer leurs déficits par
la banque centrale parce qu'en europe
c'est la banque centrale européenne et
c'est un peu à tout le monde
son objectif n'est pas de financer un
gouvernement entend tête mais les
américains le font ils l'ont fait en
2008-2009
non ouais mais on doit s'arrêter là
dessus monsieur clan mais c'est une
chose qui est clair c'est qu'on avait il
ya vu en ce moment on aura encore besoin
de vos lumières merci beaucoup
belle et bonne soirée à vous aussi